on a vous pouvez vous êtes présidente de
l'association des mères de famille du
doubs pouvez vous nous définir les buts
de cette organisation l'association de
l'aide aux mères de famille du doubs on
va écouter l'association de la nommait
en général a été créé en 1920 par madame
edouard viol est elle reconnue d'utilité
publique elle a pour but d'envoyer une
jeune fille
dans un foyer chez une mère
fatigué qui ne peut pas continuer sans
attaches familiales parce qu'elle a été
arrêtée par une maladie une naissance ou
une grande fatigue que sur le très beau
que je peux ce niveau se trouvait news
bien la travailleuse familiale remplace
la mère de famille elle s'y plaît à
la tâche journalière à l'exception de
tout gros travaux de tournus soliloque
les yeux ce besançon sont logés au
centre je crois elles sont logées oui
dans le foyer 9 rue gambetta
elle rentre le soir après leur travail
karin viard 6 heures sauf qu'ici il ya
un biberon à donner ou encore des
enfants à garder avoir autoritaire votre
action sur une pelouse aurait également
des travailleuses dans les duels du
département oui nous avons deux formes
de travail les cas en ligne ou alors la
travailleuse familiale par le matin et
en quelques fois son repas midi dans la
famille senna revient pas quand vous
voyez et on revient le soir à 6 heures
tous les soirs sauf celles qui sont
externes certainement l'après midi si
alors la loge chez leurs parents quelle
heure nous avons les cas à demain
c'est à dire que nous aidons les
familles à la campagne pour besoin de
nous dans les villages en département
lorsque je suis sur le jeu pour le
portier plus elles sont logées par les
particuliers oui elle reste
et par quelques fois par la mairie ou
recevant des subventions
de la ville département certains
organismes aurions tous vos besoins que
ces subventions augmente parce que nous
avons beaucoup à faire
et d'autre part nous avons aussi des
ententes avec les caisses de sécurité
sociale avec et d'allocations familiales
et avec divers organismes sociaux
c'est pas toi y'a pas non plus madame
jean phi vous êtes mère de dix enfants
et vous voulez la voir un gros club
récemment ils fondent au 10e jeu 10e oui
mais citi estime chez nous dans le
sondage de la gestion de
ce travail on est bien arrivé et c'est
avec 10 enfants s'est présenté vers un
certain travail
le master
les prépare comme on travaille à l'école
et ensuite la crise et forcément il ya
tout un travail le travail de la même
famille qui fait habituellement
si c'était un travail ménagers courants
le prêt pensionnaires pas les pas des
trois enfants puisqu'il ya deux jumelles
gueule encore d'une braderie qui n'ont
pas de mots claudel vous avez été malade
récemment il est obligé d'employer une
travailleuse familiale
si vous n'aviez pas eu cette
travailleuse sociale comment vous faire
ce travail comme un jeu d'enfant
donc tu nécessite beaucoup de travail
l'enlever pour
laver ligne pour passer tous les travaux
habituels du ménage nous n vous êtes à
quingey dans une famille vous êtes
travailler sur l'idéal depuis combien de
temps ça fait dix-sept jours
depuis combien de temps faut que vous
souhaitiez
et si jamais un jour vous avez
l'intention de vous marier parce que
vous continuez dans cette branche à mi
temps